- Hi, my name is Gustav.
My co-worker, Stephanie loves sloths.
Everyday she talks about sloths.
- There's three different
species of sloths.
(audio fast forwarding)
I just love sloths, they're
just like the greatest animal
and I'm gonna get emotional.
- So, me, being the nice guy that I am,
I reached out to the
Wildlife Learning Center
and asked if they had a sloth
that we could borrow for a couple of hours
so that we could surprise Stephanie
with her favorite animal.
(cheerful upbeat music)
- What?
Sloths?
Sloths!
Are you serious, Gustav?
No, we talk about this all the time.
I'm going to, one day.
(squealing)
(Gustav laughing)
This is not happening.
I can't breathe, oh my god.
How'd you get him here?
This is the greatest day of my life.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, someone,
someone call my girlfriend.
Oh my god.
Gustav, you're my best
friend in the whole world.
If you ever need a kidney, I have two.
Oh my god.
(camera shutter clicks)
I don't wanna give final thoughts
'cause that means it's over
and I don't want it to be over.
This is the greatest
experience of my life.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy.